[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 société fox news ou
réalité une question que nombreux
d'entre vous se posent à la médiathèque
du canal de montigny le bretonneux est
organisé une série de conférences
ateliers sur le thème des fêtes news de
la défiance médiatique ou encore des
réseaux sociaux
comment lutter contre l'effet que nous
c'est le sujet du jour avec nous en
plateau pour en parler ce soir séverine
pont c'est olivier bonsoir vous êtes
chargé de mission éducation aux médias
et à l'information coordonnatrice
académique du climat à côté de vous
vincent couronne fondateur des
surligneurs premier side de légal chez
king lançait en janvier 2017 par des
juristes universitaires face avoue
pierre hippolyte senlis fondateur et
vice-président de fées coffre première
association de journalistes à s'engager
contre la désinformation de masse et
enfin christophe à 100 vous êtes
l'auteur du livre réseaux sociaux tous
égaux libre ou otages du regard des
autres rumeurs théorie du complot fausse
information manipulation médiatique où
on l'entend depuis plusieurs mois
notamment depuis l'élection de donald
trump ou encore suite aux attentats de
charlie hebdo et c'est pour ça que vous
avez décidé de créer fait coffre pierre
hippolyte senlis oui alors on est une
équipe on a une trentaine de
journalistes avoir créé fait kof
on était une équipe d'une dizaine et au
fait on est parti c'était suite à
charlie hebdo on a eu un constat assez
difficile suite aux attentats qui ont
été remis en question rapidement et on
s'est rendu compte et on en est de plus
en plus convaincu qu' il fallait
renouer le débat avec les citoyens sur
le métier du journaliste est aussi que
cela passait par l'éducation fait news
qui signifie fausses informations en
français ce terme a débarqué dans notre
langage courant que signifie fake news
nous avons posé la question aux
yvelinois pour moi fait qu news comme
son nom l'indiqué ça vient de l'anglais
fait que c'est faux new ces informations
donc fausses informations à chaque fois
que je sais pas quelque chose que je
demande à plusieurs personnes
différentes pas voir plus d'avis
différents ils acquittent répète le plus
c'est le vrai c'est à chacun en fait de
faire la part des choses et puis de
vérifier prime abord les informations si
elles sont se sont justifiées ou pas il
faut aller chercher des infos partout
pour recouper le vrai du faux et se
méfient les toutes les infos ça remet en
cause beaucoup de choses qui réinterroge
à chaque fois sur la véracité de ce qui
est dit de ce qui n'est pas dit je pense
pas que c'est l'importance au final si
ce type n'est de fait le fait de faire
parler d'eux de faire de faire débattre
une finale c'est une info qui du coup
ressemble à une vraie ça peut être un
canular et des fois ça peut être une
information fausse dans l'intention de
faire passer des idées ou des messages
une réaction christophe façon je crois
que c'est c'est important de faire la
part des choses entre le canular et puis
l'intention de manipuler l'opinion
publique ou une partie des utilisateurs
par exemple des réseaux sociaux
je crois qu'il faut faire la part des
choses et une fée cno c'est ça peut être
aussi une remise en question un peu des
fondements de notre société qui est
quand même basée sur le savoir sur la
science sur le rationalisme et donc si
on raisonne purement et simplement avec
les émotions si on est influencé dont
l'opinion qu'on peut avoir à partir des
émotions
il peut y avoir un risque
pour les fondements notre société est
défectueuse que l'on retrouve parfois
dans le discours de certains politiques
avec les surligneurs vous vérifier la
conformité au droit des propos tenus par
les personnalités publiques
comment ça se passe comment vous
surligner justement les bons propos
vient on est un collectif de juristes
qui comprend à la fois des enseignants
chercheurs mais aussi des avocats aussi
des étudiants en droit d'ailleurs c'est
aussi une technique pédagogique à un peu
pour essayer de s'éduquer ou au discours
politique pour un pour un étudiant et
nous avons en fait tout un tas de
personnes qui vérifie sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les différents médias la
télévision la radio et les pros les
discours les différentes personnalités
politiques et quand il relève quelque
chose qui leur paraît juridiquement faux
ou problématiques une promesse par
exemple impossible à tenir
qui pourrait être difficilement tenable
eh bien on publie sur notre site
internet les surligneurs points ont eu
une sorte de démentis en fait en quelque
sorte mais qui et qui a la particularité
est ce qui n'est pas évident pour un
jury d'être simple clair et donc facile
à comprendre pour un non juristes et
donc remettre les chercheurs au coeur du
débat en lien avec les journalistes
c'est ce qu'il faut la dame concert
oui les chercheurs évidemment c c'est
notre notre terreau nous pour former les
enseignants ensuite a expliqué aux
élèves
pourquoi on doit pas tomber justement ce
qu'on disait dans le piège de l'émotion
de ce qui va pouvoir satisfaire un
besoin immédiat de voilà d'avoir une
information de la partager sans prendre
le temps du recul nécessaire de la
réflexion et de l'esprit critique que
l'école doit enfin auxquels l'école doit
former à tous les élèves
est ce qu'il est possible monsieur
couronne de définir juridiquement à
l'effet que news fox news non en
revanche les fausses d'information oui
la loi de 1881 déjà interdit la
diffusion de fausses informations
lorsqu'elles peuvent troubler la paix
publique
donc on sait quelque chose qui existe
dans notre droit la question des fausses
informations
en revanche il y a comment dire une
sorte de flottement sur savoir vraiment
ce que ça recouvre
est ce que par exemple ça recouvre le
canular et bien récemment le conseil
constitutionnel est venu préciser et
bien que typiquement ça ne retrouve pas
la question la caricature du canular
justement et de tout ce qui peut être
fait l'humour aussi également ne venez
pas compris dans la définition de
fausses informations
en revanche la fausse information
d'après enfin endroit et d'après notre
constitution et la décision du conseil
constitutionnel serait une information
qui serait fausse volontairement
donc voilà c'est ce que le droit nous
dit aujourd'hui de ce que c'est une
fausse information en réalité je pense
que les journalistes et la sociologie
etc peut définir comme plus largement ce
que ce ce que c est donc la solution
c'est une amende de 45 de 45000 euros
qui peut s'élever jusqu'à 135 mille
euros est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
assez pierre hippolyte 110 sur la
nouvelle loi sur les fake news sur la
loi sur la haine sur internet
nous on pense que la loi est là était
peut-être mal fait mais qu'elle n'est
pas allée assez loin qu'il ya plein de
zones qui n'ont pas été explorées que
les diffuseurs ne sont pas dus qu'on
parle pas du tout des diffuseurs de des
algorithmes de youtube et c'est donc sur
les peines pécuniaires je saurais pas
dire mais en revanche la loi les palais
du tout assez loin et en revanche elle a
créé des ouvertures un peu liberticide
sans fermer la porte à certains endroits
où sans demander des comptes notamment
diffuseur aux gaffes et c'est donc il ya
quand même un sacré boulot à faire que
ce soit sur la loi sur les faits que
muse ou sur la loi sur la haine sur
internet
il y à cette défiance médiatique
rappelez-vous avec tchernobyl incendie
lubrizol et de roulons des photos
avaient circulé avec cette information
l'eau ne serait pas potable mais le chu
de rouen a démenti à présent un autre
exemple de fait que nous mais qui a
circulé cette fois ci dans les yvelines
cette photo le 31 octobre jour
d'halloween une vidéo a été postée par
trois mineurs sur snapshot montrant ce
chat ensanglanté la séquence est partagé
sur les réseaux sociaux
et cette capture d'écran est partagée
sur le compte facebook de la ville de
mantes la jolie
elle explique que le chat a été torturé
à mort qu'un pétard allumé a été
introduit dans la bouche de l'animal et
réclame des sanctions pénales contre les
trois mineurs l'afer est même arrivé aux
oreilles d'une association locale de
protection des animaux qui s'est déplacé
au commissariat au final le chat a été
renversé c'est donc une fake news la
publication a été supprimé et christophe
à 100 vous êtes l'auteur du livre
réseaux sociaux tous ego lib otages du
regard des autres
elle les réseaux sociaux amplifie la
propagation des fake news oui dix huit
tables c'est à dire que quand on utilise
les réseaux sociaux c'est à des fins de
valoriser l'estiment de soi dans le
regard des autres et donc on cherche de
la reconnaissance sociale et on cherche
de la reconnaissance sociale en gagnant
en popularité et donc ce qu'on voit
apparaître maintenant même sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est pour certains
le fait de créer de toutes pièces des
faits que news
certes à des fins de popularité mais
parfois même pour véhiculer de vraie
publicité donc ça devient même un
business pour certaines personnes qui a
instrumentalisé la fecq news parce
qu'elles savent que ça va attirer de
l'audience et vendent leurs services à
des entreprises qui à travers le vecteur
de la fait que nous devons faire de la
publicité qui est bien réel
donc oui on est on est le réseau social
est une caisse de résonance qui amplifie
et qui joue sur ce désir d'être reconnu
dans un groupe et donc on va relayer
passivement au activement des
informations sans vérifier uniquement
parce qu'on a un besoin de
reconnaissance sociale donc c'est à la
fois la force et la fragilité
aujourd'hui des circuits d'information
c'est qu'on a tendance à pas vérifié a
pas contrôler on raisonne de manière
émotionnelle presque sentimentale alors
qu'on devrait prendre le temps du recul
mais comme vous le savez les flux
d'information continue aujourd'hui créer
une info bézy t qui fait que chacun ne
prend pas le temps du filtre je crois
qu'il faudrait de ce point de vue là qui
est un peu plus de prise de recul et de
prendre le temps de recouper les
informations entre les informations qui
proviennent des médias réel qui filtrent
l'information et des informations qui
proviennent des réseaux sociaux qui sont
transmises sans contrôle donc il
faudrait retrouver ses habitudes avant
de relayer quoi que ce soit de se dire
bon mais est-ce que je participe à une
qu'un canular une instrumentalisation
une manipulation de l'information est ce
que je porte un préjudice quelque part
ou bien est-ce que
[Musique]
l'information qui circule va éclairer
les décisions éclairées la société de
manière transparente et bienveillant et
donc ce travail il faut il faut vraiment
le faire on le fait pas ce qu'on a
besoin de gagner en reconnaissance en
popularité donc voilà c'est un peu le le
revers de la médaille aujourd'hui des
réseaux sociaux
l'importance de vérifier ses sources
vous l'avez rappelé pierre hippolyte
senlis lors de la première conférence
organisée à la médiathèque du canal vous
avez rappelé donc cette importance de
vérifier ses sources notamment par le
biais d'outils pourtant la plupart des
personnes ne connaissait pas écouter la
réaction de raymond participants pas ce
qui m'a pris ma intéressés et que je ne
connaissais pas c'est la recherche
inverse sur google d'une information on
a une photo aux pics heures de gaulle en
inverse et nous dit cette photo elle
date de talent époque il faut une plus
grande diffusion de ces outils
oui oui évidemment il existe de plus en
plus d'outils pour vérifier les
informations facilement
de plus en plus de journalistes de
médias de collectif se crée des outils
qui met à disposition du grand public
donc nous on les relais longs relais
tous et tous ces outils auprès des
enseignants et on entraîne en fait les
enseignants et les élèves à s'en servir
après évidemment le sait c'est assez
contraignant
d'utiliser des outils mais le fait de
savoir que ça existe et qu'on a le
pouvoir qu'on a le moyen de vérifier
quand même moyen de ne plus être passifs
mais d'être actifs dans cette
vérification de l'information qu'on
n'est plus une cible ni publicitaires ni
de fausses informations
c'est déjà un pas qui est fait en tout
cas pour les jeunes de savoir qu'ils
peuvent prendre la main et voilà ne plus
subir ce flot de fausses et multiples
informations
et sachez que certains sites offrent de
manière gratuite ce service de
vérification
c'est le cas de aux axes buster points
comme le site s'affiche en bas de votre
écran et des représentants de la presse
française journalistes et citoyens
fondée à paris elle début décembre le
conseil de déontologie journalistique et
de médiation est il nécessaire d'agir
sur cette question est des fausses
informations
nous avons posé la question à marie le
bec et député de la 4e circonscription
des yvelines
écoutez il ya eu des mesures
législatives qui ont été prises au début
du quinquennat
mais je crois qu'au delà de ce qu'on
peut faire en matière législative il ya
un vrai travail notamment salué moi j'en
ai un certain nombre dans ma
circonscription les écoles les collèges
les lycées qui s'engagent justement pour
apprendre aux élèves à repérer
défectueux vous êtes coordonnatrice du
clemi le centre pour l'éducation aux
médias et à l'information est derrière
toutes ces histoires de fake news est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un problème d'éducation
et de bon sens évidemment ce que je
disais tout à l'heure la base de tout
c'est l'éducation à l'esprit critique et
qui entend prendre le temps d'analyser
prendre le temps de réfléchir prendre le
le temps de faire un pas en arrière mans
auteur tout dépend comment se place le
la question de l'éducation aux médias à
être présente depuis très longtemps à
l'école mais a trouvé un écho
particulier après 2015 et avec le la loi
pour les valeurs de la république enfin
le parcours citoyen qui en fait permet
aux élèves d'avoir une entrée dans
l'éducation aux médias de la maternelle
jusqu'au lycée
donc à tous les stades de son éducation
l'élève va être confronté à cette
question d'éducation aux médias qui va
de la connaissance des médias savoir ce
qu'est en médias et ce qui n'en est pas
un faire la différence entre un journal
et un youtube heures entre un
influenceur est un vrai journaliste
donc tout ça c'est effectivement des
choses qu'on leur apprend et puis
ensuite on travaille beaucoup sur la
production de médias pour dire créer
soi-même son information allait aller la
rechercher vérifier ses sources
choisir un point de vue ça permet de le
confronter en fait à ce qu'est
l'information et et toutes les impasses
dans lesquelles on peut tomber
et voilà donc production de médias et
puis bien sûr maintenant tout ce qui
concerne la citoyenneté numérique c'est
à dire quels sont mes droits et mes
devoirs en matière de publications en
particulier sur les réseaux sociaux et
les sites internet
les jeunes sont les plus touchés 83% des
mondes de 35 ans en forme principalement
sur internet contre 62 % pour l'ensemble
des français
une omniprésence qui rend les jeunes
plus vulnérables aux fausses
informations
que faut-il faire enfin sans couronne je
vais aller dans le sens un peu de ce qui
a été dit jusque là c'est à dire que
l'éducation est
et je vais même aller un peu plus loin
je pense que la loi qui a été votée en
2018 est totalement inutile
elle ne servirait que dans quelques cas
rares ou linfo re la force informations
elle les fausses aux yeux de tout le
monde et tout le monde a compris qu'elle
était fausse dans ce cas là à quoi ça
sert de la retirer si on a tous compris
qu'elle était fausse d'autre part je
trouve que ce qui comme entière ne pas
très optimiste ce que je vais dire mais
le faire du fact checking et ce que nous
faisons au surligneur sur le droit n'a
pas une utilité kippen tels que ça
permettrait de renverser en fait les
fausses informations qui sont beaucoup
beaucoup plus vue est beaucoup plus que
les correctifs que nous publions ou
quand même les décodeurs dumont publie
ou que même le france info etc a fait
s'est il faut se rendre compte quand
même que c'est une goutte d'eau dans un
océan de fausses informations notre
travail et par conséquent je ne vois pas
d'autres moyens que l'éducation en fait
pour essayer de réduire en fait la
diffusion de fausse information
il ya un autre élément si on veut
vraiment passer par la loi à mon sens
faire des lois qui sont liberticides et
qui donne comme la loi sur le projet de
loi la proposition de loi plutôt pardon
sur la cyberhaine qui propose de forcer
les plateformes elle-même à contrôler le
contenu de ce qui est posté sur leur
site pour retirer les propos haineux etc
ce qui à mon avis est une grave atteinte
à notre vie privée et à la liberté
au lieu de faire ce genre de choses en
fait qu'il faudrait arriver à faire
c'est casser le modèle économique de ces
plates formes là parce que comme ça a
été très bien dit tout à l'heure
le vrai problème de l' effusion défaut
d'information c'est que ça rapporte
facebook fait semblant exagère un peu il
participe à la lutte contre les fausses
informations en réalité ça c'est pour
montrer patte blanche en quelque sorte
publiquement mais ils ont encore intérêt
à ce que ce modèle de l'économie du clic
et de la fausse information s'effondre
parce que c'est sûr ça qu'ils gagnent
essentiellement de l'argent
facebook et d'autres une réaction je
suis globalement d'accord on essaie de
leur parler aussi quoi notamment aux
jeunes de responsabilité c'est à dire on
est responsable aussi de là où on clique
on est responsable de ce qu'on partage
parce que c'est vrai que pourquoi on
ment sur internet il ya des histoires
d'idéologie mais c'est beaucoup de
modèles économiques on a des gens qui
font des carrières ou des fortunes
uniquement là dessus
on a des chaînes ultra populaire chez
les jeunes enfants comme lahm a fâché ou
des qui ont des contenus essentiellement
faut et qui crée des mânes économique
assez énorme et tant qu'on n'attaque pas
ça tant qu'on n'attaque pas youtube qui
continue de proposer des contenus qui
ont été signalés on n'avance pas et ça
c'est difficile à faire mais il faut une
volonté politique aussi pour pouvoir le
faire
il existe également des sites de fake
news comme le gora fille ou the oignons
aux états unis faut-il les retirer mais
chassang alors je connais pas vraiment
ses sites web ce que j'aurais tendance à
dire d'une manière plus générale c'est
que on est confronté à un problème
effectivement de société à travers les
faits close mais qui dépasse
probablement toutes les mesures qu'on
pourrait imaginer dans déontologique
éducatives ou même juridique
pourquoi parce que c'est un problème qui
mondialise et c'est à dire qu'internet
les réseaux sociaux c'est sans
frontières et donc il faut il faut
imaginer que la réponse viendra à partir
des usages il faut corriger les usages
les usages collectifs à l'échelle
mondiale et ça c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce qu'il ya quand même
effectivement des enjeux économiques on
vient de le signaler mais il ya aussi
des enjeux géopolitiques
on voit dans cette manche certaines
élections politiques l'ingérence de pays
pour fausser le déroulement des
élections
à partir de leur propre pays et donc
étudier les dérives d'internet c'est
quelque part étudier les limites de
souveraineté nationale dans
l'établissement de règles
donc on est dans un problème qui est
mondiale aussi difficile à régler que le
problème climatologiques ou d'autres
problèmes qui ont une ampleur mondiale
voilà ce que je peux dire je suis assez
d'accord et est du coup le changement de
comportement via l'éducation peut
permettre localement déjà de mettre à
l'abri entre guillemets un certaines
populations et puis petit à petit ogre
espérons de pouvoir faire changer les
pratiques elles mêmes sur internet mais
pour répondre à votre première question
je pense pas qu'il faille interdire logo
rafuse union parce que ça ce sont des
sites qui font du canular et le canular
ce n'est pas de la fausse information
mais là où l'éducation est importante
c'est apprendre aussi aux gens à faire
différence entre ce qui relève du
canular et ce qui relève de
l'information justement faut-il proposer
une formation un peu plus spécifique
contre tous à un canular fait que news
alors plus spécifique c'est compliqué
parce que les élèves ont quand même
beaucoup de choses à apprendre
l'éducation médias et l'information
c'est vraiment un enseignement
transversal c'est à dire qu'on peut
l'aborder dans des tas de discipline en
français et en maths notamment pour tout
ce qui est la lecture de statistiques
l'interprétation des chiffres en
sciences physiques chimie pour tout ce
qui est vérification des faits
scientifiques
donc c'est un enseignement transversal
il faut juste que effectivement les
enseignants sans par tous de cette
question et pas seulement d'enseignants
d'éducation les civic ou et ça c'est
notre travail de proposer à tous les
enseignants d'intégrer ces notions
d'éducation et d'information de
vérification d'informations de travail
de l'esprit critique à travers chacun
des objets d'enseignement qui proposent
à leurs élèves
avant de clôturer cette émission à faire
un petit tour de table pour rappeler
quels sont les bons gestes pour ne pas
tomber dans l'effet que nous on commence
par vous déjà on peut assez facilement
aller chercher des informations souvent
se rend compte que les gens ne font même
pas l'effort d'aller faire une petite
recherche sur google on peut en
regardant
un article voir si on cite des sources
s'il est signé
si la personne est anonyme ne serait ce
que des choses si j'étais si j'étais
masqués devant vous le niveau de
confiance que vous m'accorderez serait
moindre
c'est un peu ça l'anonymat sur internet
où les gens qui signent pas donc il ya
des réflexes assez facile déjà il ya
assez facilement on peut on peut quand
même se rendre compte de la véracité ou
en tout cas du sérieux d'une personne ou
d'une source
et après il ya des outils pour vérifier
qu'ils sont assez simples vérifier des
photos vérifier des sites
ça c'est quand même je crois que ce qui
est important c'est un moment de se
déconnecter des écrans quand on utilise
un écran on utilise à peu près 15 % de
ses facultés cognitives
donc on est relativement passives et
vulnérables je crois que science
déconnecte on va redécouvrir le monde et
peut-être renforcer sa culture générale
qui est peut-être le premier élément
pour cultiver l'esprit critique dont on
a tellement besoin aujourd'hui
je crois que c'est le conseil qu'il faut
donner aux jeunes générations
certes les nouveaux outils sont très
précieux il faut pas en être dépendant
aux poindre au point de perdre tout
esprit critique et donc aller chercher
aussi la culture générale en dehors des
écrans
ça permet de relativiser et ensuite de
traiter l'information plus sereinement
il a tiré dans le même sens évidemment
dans la question de prendre du temps
prendre du temps avant de partager
diffuser une information voilà faire le
minimum de vérifications généralement
quand une information provoque une
émotion assez fortes se poser et prendre
le temps de venir réfléchir et je dirais
peut-être pour ajouter lire les sur
niort points
je voudrais un petit chose s'est
questionné ses propres ses propres
opinions pourquoi je crois ça pourquoi
je partage ça il ne serait ce que sas
quand j'entendais parler de cognitif
parce que c'est vraiment important et
appartements questionne ses propres à
priori ou ses propres opinions
on prend du recul et on prend du temps
aussi donc je pense que c'est important
le rôle du citoyen une conférence débat
journalistes et réseaux sociaux se
tiendra demain jeudi 7 janvier de 19h à
20h30 à la médiathèque du canal de saint
quentin en yvelines
cette soirée est gratuite sur
inscription via le site qui s'affiche
d'autres rendez vous sont prévus c'est
la fin de ce sept huit sociétés merci
d'avoir suivi cette émission sur les
faits que new soyez vigilants belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
il